- Monsieur Sarkozy,
je vous félicite pour votre élection.
Vous méritez la confiance
du peuple français.
- Monsieur Kadhafi,
je suis enchanté de vous parler.
Je n'ai pas oublié notre rencontre.
Je garde un excellent souvenir
de la qualité de vos analyses.
Vous méritez amplement
votre titre de guide.
- Je suis rassuré d'avoir,
avec vous, un ami en Europe.
Je vous sais ambitieux et volontaire.
Nous ferons beaucoup
de choses entre nos deux pays.
- Oui, Monsieur le guide.
J'espère vous recevoir en France
ou me rendre en Libye.
- Incha'Allah, Incha'Allah.
- Je compte sur votre prière,
Monsieur le guide.
Je ne prie pas
de la même manière que vous,
mais je prie
le même Dieu que vous.
- Merci infiniment.
- Je vous exprime mes respects
et mon amitié Monsieur le guide.
- Le 28 mai 2007,
l'un des tout
premiers dirigeants du monde
à qui le président français,
tout juste élu, téléphonait longuement,
était le chef
d'un petit pays d'Afrique du Nord.
Dès le début, donc, au-dessus de lui,
planait l'ombre du dictateur.
Bientôt, celui-ci
viendra le visiter en ces lieux.
Il l'obsédera jusqu'aux derniers
instants de son mandat
et continuera
de le hanter après.
Jamais sous
la Cinquième République,
un dictateur n'avait ainsi
marqué de son empreinte
le quinquennat d'un président.
Toute cette histoire a commencé
que le futur président n'entre à l’Élysée,
que le futur président n'entre à l'Elysée,
lorsqu'il est allé faire
la connaissance du dictateur
un jour d'octobre 2005.
Il est alors un fringuant ministre
de l'Intérieur de Jacques Chirac,
qui ne fait pas mystère
de ses ambitions présidentielles.
Depuis l'aéroport,
son convoi file à travers Tripoli,
capitale d'un État
de six millions d'habitants
que la manne pétrolière
a rendu le plus riche d'Afrique.
Sur les murs,
s'affiche partout l'homme qui le dirige
d'une main de fer depuis 1969.
Officiellement, le ministre
a été convié ici à venir s'entretenir
de la lutte antiterroriste
et de l'immigration irrégulière.
Pourquoi voulez-vous aller en Italie ?
Je voulais partir.
- Je veux contrôler les choses.
- En coulisse toutefois,
cette visite a pour le ministre
d'autres enjeux plus personnels.
Elle a été initiée
par un homme de l'ombre, un Libanais.
Un intermédiaire en armement,
à la fois proche de plusieurs
membres de son entourage
et familier du pouvoir libyen.
En 2005,
je rencontre le fils du colonel Kadhafi,
en visite privée en France.
Il m'invite en Libye
pour aller rencontrer son père,
le colonel Kadhafi,
et je rencontre Kadhafi.
Quand je lui parlais
de Nicolas Sarkozy,
je parlais de lui comme
quelqu'un qui allait
changer beaucoup
la démarche française en général,
dans le domaine
de la politique extérieure.
C'est Seïf
qui s'est emballé sur Sarkozy.
C'est Seïf qui a poussé
son père papa, papa
papa il est formidable.
Je retourne en France,
je vois Monsieur Guéant
et les choses se sont mises en place.
Monsieur Claude Guéant était venu
préparer la visite plusieurs fois.
Je l'ai vu au moins
deux fois, pas forcément une fois.
Monsieur Claude Guéant
avait ses propres contacts.
- Signe de l'importance
qu'il accorde à cette relation,
Son plus proche
collaborateur devient dès lors
son agent
de liaison avec les libyens.
En fin de matinée,
devant la tente bédouine
plantée au milieu
de son palais caserne,
apparaît le dictateur.
Depuis peu,
il n'est plus un chef d'État paria
à la tête
d'un pays sous embargo.
En renonçant au terrorisme
et à l'arme nucléaire,
il est devenu fréquentable
aux yeux des Occidentaux.
Sous cette tente,
il a déjà reçu des dirigeants européens.
Ce jour-là, il surprend ceux
qui connaissent ses habitudes,
comme l'ambassadeur français
en poste à Tripoli depuis quatre ans.
Colonel Kadhafi
ne recevait jamais le matin
car il avait des nuits
sans doute très longues
et le matin, il était toujours un peu
dans le brouillard si j'ose dire.
C'était plutôt le soir,
l'après-midi ou plutôt le soir.
Là, il l'a reçu tout de suite.
La diplomate Zorah Mansour
est une intime du dictateur,
la responsable
de ses fameuses amazones.
Le guide m'a dit,
Zorah nous honorons quelqu'un
qui sera candidat
à des élections importantes.
S'il arrivait au pouvoir,
nous pourrions entretenir
de bonnes relations avec son pays.
Ça vaut le coup, non ?
Ils me l'ont dit.
C'était l'objectif principal.
On accueille monsieur Sarkozy
parce qu'on sait
qu'il peut avoir un destin important
en France et être le futur président.
Enfin, l'ambitieux ministre,
novice sur la scène internationale
et l'indéboulonnable dictateur,
au pouvoir depuis
36 ans, font connaissance.
Bienvenue.
- Enchanté.
Prenez place
je vous en prie.
L'empressement du libyen
à rencontrer ce possible
président français a une raison.
Merci de me recevoir
malgré le ramadan.
Après avoir vainement tenté
de prendre la tête du monde arabe,
le dictateur rêve
de fonder des États-Unis d'Afrique.
Que bien sûr, il dirigerait.
Autoproclamé roi des rois, ses milliards
lui donnent les moyens de ses ambitions.
Sur sa route, il craint la France
et sa très active politique africaine.
La France, qui s'est toujours
opposée à ses projets.
Ainsi, ses rapports
avec le président Chirac
sont-ils notoirement glaciaux.
Il fallait donc améliorer nos relations
avec la France coûte que coûte
pour qu'elle ne perturbe pas par
son influence sur certains pays africains,
les discussions sur la fondation
des États-Unis d'Afrique.
C'était notre but
et c'est ce qu'on attendait de Sarkozy
à l'époque ministre de l'Intérieur.
L'un des hommes chargé des relations
avec la France est le cousin du dictateur,
son stratège, son confident.
Une chose est sûre,
il nous a montré le plus grand respect.
Il nous a fait l'impression
d'un homme honnête
qui voulait sincèrement
développer nos relations
et corriger les erreurs
de la France en Afrique.
Le dictateur ne peut qu'apprécier
ce ministre qui prône publiquement
la rupture avec le président
français du moment.
Il s'en retourne en France
avec le pouvoir à conquérir.
S'il ne revient pas en Libye,
plusieurs de
ses proches feront le voyage.
Parfois pour parler affaire.
Après les années d'embargo,
le juteux marché
libyen suscite des convoitises.
Ainsi, l'homme d'affaires Takieddine
effectue de nombreux séjours
dans les grands hôtels de Tripoli.
Il utilise ses relations
dans l'entourage du futur président
pour emporter des contrats d'armement
et évince ainsi des intermédiaires
implantés de plus longue date.
J'ai mes clients eux-mêmes
qui viennent vers moi
et qui me disent Ziad Takieddine
est arrivé avec un courrier
à entête du ministère de l'Intérieur.
Sarkozy était ministre de l'Intérieur
et dans le courrier, il y avait :
Je recommande
chaudement monsieur Ziad Takieddine,
homme de l'industrie
très connu par nos services.
Un homme remarquable pour
les industriels Thales, Dassault, Snecma.
Allons-y !
Pourquoi pas MacDo ?
Il y en avait
pour tous les goûts
et signé Monsieur Sarkozy.
J'ai su après que Sarkozy
a été interrogé à l’Élysée.
Sarkozy dit écoutez,
soyons sérieux, vous avez une copie.
On lui a répondu non,
on n'a pas de copie.
Alors écoutez,
vous connaissez les libanais.
C'est ce que j'ai su qu'il aurait répondu,
il connaissait les Libanais.
Ce n'est pas lui qui me mandate.
Par contre, Nicolas Sarkozy a reçu
officiellement ma désignation
comme interlocuteur
de la part des Libyens avec lui.
Le futur président ne sait peut-être pas
tout ce qui se trame autour de lui
ou en son nom.
Pourtant,
entre lui et le dictateur,
il flotte dès
lors un fumet affairiste
qui ne sera pas sans conséquence
à la fin de cette histoire.
Je veux être le président
de la France des droits de l'Homme
parce que je le crois
au plus profond de mon cœur.
Je ne veux pas, je ne crois pas
à ce qu'on appelle la realpolitik
qui fait renoncer à ses valeurs.
Je ne veux être complice
d'aucune dictature à travers le monde.
En janvier 2007,
celui qui exprimait
son respect au dictateur
lance sa campagne présidentielle
sur un bien autre ton.
Gagner une élection vaut bien de
se poser en chantre des droits de l'Homme,
surtout lorsqu'on est précédé
par une réputation
de ministre de l'Intérieur à poigne.
- C'était l'époque
où une certaine gauche intellectuelle
s'insurgeait de ses propos
et à un moment donné,
on a senti chez lui le besoin
de s'adresser à ces intellectuels-là.
Parce que, même s'ils ne sont
pas majoritaires dans le pays,
ils ont une certaine influence.
Nicolas Sarkozy était
très sensible à ce que pouvaient penser
les Bernard-Henri Levy,
les Glucksmann, les Bruckner.
Les droits de l'Homme
ne pouvait pas ne pas me plaire.
En plus, il est vrai
que Nicolas Sarkozy avait un langage
et dans sa campagne,
des thèmes qui étaient très nouveaux
par rapport
à l'orthodoxie de la droite.
Deuxième grand
objectif de la France,
promouvoir les libertés
et les droits de l'Homme
sur la scène internationale.
Je ne me tairai jamais devant
ces insultes aux droits de l'Homme.
Bien la France.
Elle n'est-elle même que
quand elle promeut la liberté
contre l'oppression.
- C'est ainsi qu'à l'issue de la campagne,
il recrute deux personnalités atypiques
qui compteront
dans la suite de cette histoire.
De Bernard Kouchner
héros de l'humanitaire,
il fera son ministre
des affaires étrangères.
Il invente une fonction inédite
sous la Cinquième République,
celle de secrétaire d'État
aux droits de l'Homme,
qu'il confiera
à la jeune Rama Yade.
- C'est Nicolas Sarkozy
qui est élu président de la République
avec 53 % des voix.
Résultat salué par une ovation
de ses supporteurs, Salle Gaveau.
- Salle Gaveau,
un célèbre théâtre parisien.
La foule ignore qu'elle va assister
au premier acte de la pièce
que le nouvel élu s'apprête
à jouer avec le dictateur.
Après les généreuses paroles du candidat,
place aux actes du président.
Sans grande surprise,
il fait un discours de vainqueur.
Salle Gaveau à Paris,
devant ses supporters.
Puis, dans l'euphorie générale,
il place le début de son mandat
sur le terrain
de la politique étrangère.
C'est en Méditerranée
que tout va se jouer.
Qu'il nous faut
surmonter toutes les haines
pour laisser la place
à un grand rêve de paix
et à un grand rêve de civilisation.
Le temps est venu
de bâtir une union méditerranéenne
qui sera un trait d'union
entre l'Europe et l'Afrique.
Ce qui a été fait
pour l'union de l'Europe il y a 60 ans,
nous allons le faire aujourd'hui
pour l'union de la Méditerranée.
- Réunir tous les pays riverains
de la Méditerranée
au sein d'une union politique,
telle est sa spectaculaire
et surprenante promesse.
Tout juste élu et déjà,
il aspire à un coup de maître
qui prouverait à tous
qu'il est ce grand président
pareil à nul autre
qu'il promettait d'être.
Pour réussir son pari,
il a besoin du soutien
d'un État d'Afrique du Nord.
Incontournable
autant que peu coopératif,
dirigé par
un peu commode dictateur.
Le nouveau président a de bonnes raisons
de penser qu'il trouvera en lui un allié.
En ce début de quinquennat,
tous les chemins le mènent en Libye.
Il s'attelle sans tarder
à son union pour la Méditerranée,
s'efforçant de convaincre
les chefs d'État de la région d'y adhérer.
Il a aussi en tête les grands contrats
qu'il pourrait obtenir de la riche Libye.
Lui qui a promis de ramener milliards
et emplois aux entreprises françaises.
Puis, cerise sur le gâteau.
Il saisit l'opportunité
de réaliser un bon coup de communication
qui contribuerait à sa gloire.
À Tripoli en effet,
l'imprévisible guide libyen
a suscité un nouvel obstacle
dans ses relations avec l'Occident.
Il détient cinq infirmières bulgares
dont le calvaire émeut
l'opinion internationale.
Injustement accusées d'avoir
inoculé le virus du sida à des enfants,
torturées, elles viennent
d'être condamnées à mort.
Depuis des mois, l'Union européenne
négocie leur libération avec le dictateur.
Ok, suivez-moi Madame.
Par ici.
En ce mois de juillet 2007,
la commissaire
aux relations extérieures
est sur le point de réussir.
Dans une journée,
parce qu'ils changeaient toujours tout,
on a négocié ça
et c'était prêt à signer.
Là, nous voulions signer,
tout à coup,
les Libyens ont coupé tout.
Ils voulaient savoir,
oui, on n'est pas sûrs.
Nous avons fait le travail.
On ne savait pas
que Sarkozy négociait derrière.
À l’Élysée,
dans la plus grande discrétion,
entouré de
sa seule garde rapprochée,
Jean-David Levitte,
son conseiller diplomatique
Henri Guaino et
l'indispensable Claude Guéant,
le président joue
en personne les négociateurs.
- On me passe
un coup de téléphone.
Le président Sarkozy
aimerait parler à Kadhafi.
Dis-nous où se trouve Kadhafi
à 14 h ou à 17 h ?
C'est comme ça
que les choses se passaient.
J'ai eu au moins
quatre coups de téléphone.
Pour les sauver, il fallait
aussi accepter, en contrepartie,
de discuter
avec le colonel Kadhafi.
Ça a beaucoup joué,
parce que Kadhafi
se sentait considéré.
Quand vous recevez
un coup de téléphone,
quand vous recevez
un message écrit c'est une chose,
mais qu'ensuite vous voyez,
quinze jour après,
un nouvel appel,
à trois ou quatre reprises, ça marque.
Surtout avec ces pays-là
qui sont les pays
où la relation humaine est fondamentale.
Pour devenir le libérateur
des innocentes infirmières,
le président est prêt à offrir beaucoup.
Il sait que le dictateur
rêve d'effectuer
une prestigieuse
visite officielle en Occident
pour marquer son retour
sur la scène internationale.
C'est en échange du sauvetage
des infirmières bulgares
qu'a été faite la promesse
de recevoir le colonel Kadhafi
en visite d'État à Paris.
Le président accède
à un autre désir cher au dictateur.
Affligé d'avoir dû renoncer
à l'arme nucléaire,
le Libyen veut posséder
au moins une centrale nucléaire,
symbole de puissance.
Depuis des mois,
il sollicite les autorités françaises,
jusqu'à présent circonspectes
face aux caprices
d'un dictateur réputé incontrôlable.
Des gens qui étaient tout à fait
opposés à s'aventurer ou à s'engager,
ce n'est pas une aventure.
À s'engager dans cette voie,
même à pas comptés.
Là-dessus,
le président de la République a arbitré
parce que là, à chaque reprise,
dans les entretiens
auxquels j'ai assisté,
à plusieurs reprises, le président
Kadhafi, ça lui tenait à cœur ce point-là.
C'était un personnage
extrêmement intelligent,
très manœuvrier,
un homme de pouvoir très efficace.
Il a tiré tout le parti
qu'il pouvait tirer de cette négociation.
Ils n'ont pas cherché
à obtenir davantage.
C'est l'accord de défense
qui a fait un tout petit peu de problème.
Parce que les Libyens voulaient
une sorte de clause de défense
en disant que s'ils étaient attaqués,
la France devait les aider.
Il n'était pas question de ça
et je sais que mon homologue libyen
m'a dit, je n'ai pas pu obtenir.
Je lui ai dit c'est exclu,
il ne faut pas chercher.
Ça ne passera jamais.
Le dictateur a obtenu presque
tout ce qu'il pouvait espérer.
Dans la nuit du 22 juillet 2007,
le deal est scellé.
Quarante-huit heures
plus tard, en Bulgarie,
un avion de la République Française
rend la liberté aux malheureuses.
Des dizaines de journalistes sont venus
retransmettre ce succès présidentiel.
Ils découvrent alors qu'il comporte
un inattendu volet conjugal.
Madame Sarkozy.
Pour aller chercher
les infirmières en Libye,
le président s'est fait représenter
par sa femme, Cécilia.
Un geste envers le dictateur
et peut-être même plus que cela.
On est des Arabes, vous savez.
Il a envoyé sa femme à Tripoli,
ça compte.
Ça nous était difficile
de refuser la demande d'une femme
sur un sujet comme celui-là.
Je crois que pour lui,
c'était important aussi
pour montrer à Cécilia
qu'elle pouvait jouer
un grand rôle si elle restait.
C'est un peu
ce que j'ai compris
quand elle était
avec moi dans l'avion.
Il espère, à travers l'affaire libyenne,
qu'elle va trouver sa place
et que, comme cela a marché,
il imagine qu'il va pouvoir
la garder, comme ça.
- Madame Sarkozy.
Avec sa femme,
le président vit une crise de couple.
Il cherche à la retenir
par tous les moyens,
y compris
les moins conventionnels.
- Madame Sarkozy.
Baroque,
exercice du pouvoir
où diplomatie
et vie privée se mêlent.
Mesdames et Messieurs, je vous remercie
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
dans des délais aussi brefs.
Je voulais vous dire
quelle était notre joie
devant la fin de ce long calvaire
qui a frappé cinq femmes.
Puis vous comprendrez
que je dise également
que Cécilia a fait un travail
tout à fait remarquable.
Que pourrait une phrase courte
et n'en est pas moins très sincère.
Deux mois seulement
après son arrivée au pouvoir,
le dictateur lui offre
cette victoire diplomatique éclatante
de surcroît parée
de bons sentiments de toutes sortes.
Ce ne sont pas les interrogations
de la presse qui vont gâcher ce moment.
On sait bien que rien ne se fait
avec le colonel Kadhafi sans compensation.
Si vous me poser la question
la France a-t-elle versé un euro ?
Ma réponse, c'est non.
De quoi s'agissait-il ?
Il s'agissait d'arracher
cinq malheureuses femmes
à un sort bien peu enviable.
Il y avait un problème
à résoudre, on l'a résolu, point.
Pour servir nos intérêts,
dans notre projet africain,
nous avions décidé de soutenir
Nicolas Sarkozy dans cette affaire,
par tous les moyens.
En l'occurrence, nous voulions
lui donner une carte à jouer.
Cette carte,
le président va venir la jouer en Libye
dès le lendemain.
Deux ans après son premier séjour,
le président est de retour à Tripoli.
L'ambassadeur méritant
et le chef du protocole libyen
l'attendent au bas du tapis rouge.
Il est accueilli en grande pompe
et en terrain connu.
- Bienvenu.
Soyez le bienvenu dans notre pays
Merci
- Voici notre ministre
des affaires étrangères.
Monsieur Bachir (secrétaire de Kadhafi)
La libération des infirmières
est pour le président des droits
de l'Homme, un paravent commode.
Qui s'offusquerait en effet
de cette escale à Tripoli,
au lendemain
d'une si émouvante libération ?
Il peut passer en toute quiétude
aux choses sérieuses avec le dictateur.
Autant la première visite
avait été un peu fade, discrète,
autant alors là,
ça a été la fiesta.
Dans le jardin de sa caserne,
au pied d'un bâtiment
laissé en l'état
depuis le bombardement
américain de 1986,
c'est un dictateur
en tenue d'apparat
qui accueille le président
et son importante délégation.
Parmi elles se trouve la jeune secrétaire
d'État aux droits de l'Homme, Rama Yade.
Arrivé à moi, il me serre la main
et je lui serre la main.
Il était d'ailleurs étrange,
on n'aurait pas dit un président
parce qu’il était habillé
en costume blanc avec sur la poitrine
une carte de l'Afrique
en plastique noir
et puis des lunettes de soleil.
Ses cheveux tout mouillés
ou huileux, je ne sais pas trop.
Il se pensait le représentant de l'Afrique
et moi étant d'origine africaine,
il a dû penser qu'on devait avoir
une complicité particulière.
Il me dit mais comment à 30 ans,
vous êtes ministre ?
Moi, du tac au tac,
je réponds :
« Vous à 27 ans, vous aviez bien
fait un coup d'État. »
Là, je vois le regard
du président Sarkozy
qui part dans tous les sens.
Puis lui,
ça le fait rire manifestement.
L'heure est à l'idylle,
surtout lorsque vient la signature
d'une dizaine
d'accords de coopération.
- Je ne sais pas combien
il y a de documents.
Qu'est-ce qu'on signe comme
accords, je ne m'en plains pas.
Auparavant,
c'est moi qui avait été chargée
de rédiger ces accords.
Le guide m'a dit textuellement :
« Zorah, s'agissant de la France,
il ne faut pas t'inquiéter,
Sarkozy est notre ami,
tout va bien pour nous. »
L'accord sur la défense en particulier,
a de quoi réjouir le dictateur.
La France entraînera
ses forces spéciales
et lui fournira
les armes les plus modernes.
À la suite de ce rapprochement,
les Français lui vendront même
un système de surveillance d'Internet
qu'il utilisera
pour traquer ses opposants.
Ceci, il est vrai,
pèse à l'époque fort peu dans la balance.
Quand vous faites
des contrats de vente d'armes,
vous imaginez
bien que le gouvernement
peut effectivement
les utiliser d'une autre manière
que pour préserver
l'indépendance nationale.
Faut-il donc
ne plus vendre d'armes à quiconque ?
Il vont toujours trouver quelqu'un
pour leur vendre des armes.
Là encore, c'est la difficulté.
Difficulté morale de tout ça,
mais le monde est comme il est.
Pour le président,
ces accords sont de moindre importance
à côté du dossier qu'il a prévu d'évoquer
dans quelques minutes avec le dictateur.
Sa chère union pour la Méditerranée.
Après deux mois de présidence,
elle semble à portée de main.
Il a besoin toutefois du soutien
déterminant de son hôte.
C'était un axe majeur
de sa politique étrangère.
Lui, arrivait
avec un esprit cartésien
et une discussion structurée en tête.
En face, l'interlocuteur n'était pas
dans les mêmes dispositions
intellectuelles, disons.
J'ai le souvenir
d'une scène de théâtre,
d'une incommunication flagrante
d'une comédie jouée
par Mouammar Kadhafi.
Avec tout l'enthousiasme
dont il est capable,
le président expose sa vision géopolitique
au maître des lieux
à qui il offre de le rallier.
C'était un sphinx.
Il ne répondait pas ou il disait
trois ou quatre mots en arabe,
sans rapport du tout avec la discussion
qu'on voulait avoir avec lui.
Il y avait des éclairages
sur ce qu'on pouvait lui vendre.
En général, c'était je ne sais pas quoi,
des armes anti-chars.
Nous ne savions pas,
il fallait qu'on prenne des conseils.
Le dictateur élude.
Bernard Kouchner recentre
la discussion avec un peu d'insistance.
Le président l'a repris
en disant pratiquement,
Kadhafi, n'écoutez pas ce que dit
mon ministre des Affaires étrangères.
Sarkozy voulait
une visite qui se passe bien.
Il disait, je suis là pour
faire plaisir à mon hôte.
Autant ne pas évoquer
les choses dans le détail.
En gros, le président a dit
on verra, on vous précisera les choses,
les grandes lignes, tout ça.
Lorsqu'il quitte la tente,
le président ne doute pas
de gagner son hôte à sa cause.
Le dictateur, lui,
masque sa déception.
Il escomptait un président
acquis à ses rêves africains.
Il reçoit un ambitieux qui lui demande
de se rallier à un projet concurrent.
Nous pensions
que Sarkozy avait pris en compte
le projet
que nous avions impulsé en Afrique.
Là, nous constatons qu'il cherche
juste à se donner un rôle historique
et qu'il veut être le chef.
Kadhafi a toujours eu
cette ambition un peu fantasque,
de rassembler l'Afrique
ou en tout cas une partie de l'Afrique.
Il a essayé d'atteindre
cet objectif plus par l'ingérence
que par la coopération.
Notre message assez évident
était de lui dire puisque
vous avez renoncé au terrorisme
et aux armes de destruction massive,
renoncez aussi à l'ingérence,
à la déstabilisation de vos voisins.
Trop sûr de lui, le président mésestime
les ambitions du roi des rois d'Afrique.
Bref, l'entrevue
se révèle un jeu de dupes.
Chacun se méprenant
sur les intentions de l'autre.
Dans la soirée, Nicolas Sarkozy
nous retrouve à l'hôtel
où là,
il va débriefer longuement
son entrevue avec Kadhafi.
Il est très content de cette affaire.
Il ne cesse
de la raconter tant et plus.
Il est très content
de son début de mandat
qu'il veut absolument marquer
par un gros coup sur le plan diplomatique.
Son grand dessein,
c'est de réunir tout le monde.
Il ajoute Kadhafi
dans son puzzle.
Les échos que j'en ai eu, c'est
que les choses s'étaient bien passées.
Le colonel Kadhafi
s'était montré très ouvert
sur l'idée d'une union
pour la Méditerranée.
De retour vers la France,
il reste à l'hyper président,
comme on commence à le surnommer,
à honorer une promesse.
La visite officielle
qu'il a offerte au dictateur.
Il compte bien
qu'elle renforce son entente avec lui
et parachève sa grande
offensive diplomatique de début de mandat.
Cinq mois plus tard, en décembre.
La femme du président
est finalement partie.
Le dictateur arrive.
La veille de sa venue,
les deux hommes se croisent à Lisbonne
dans le cadre
d'un sommet international.
Bonjour Monsieur Kadhafi.
Je suis très heureux
de vous recevoir en visite à Paris
Le président va recevoir
un dictateur resté fidèle à lui-même.
Il vient de faire scandale
en déclarant à un journal portugais,
« Il est normal que les faibles
aient recours au terrorisme ».
Permettez-moi de
dire qu'il y a moins de problèmes
à recevoir le président Kadhafi,
dont les services collaborent
avec les services occidentaux
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme,
dont les infirmières ont été libérées
dans un avion de la République Française.
Pour le reste,
il a sa personnalité, son tempérament.
Ce n'est pas moi
qui vais les juger.
Au petit matin ce lundi,
on déroule le tapis rouge,
par rouleaux entiers.
Dans la cour d'honneur
de l’Élysée et en face,
dans les jardins d'une annexe du palais.
Première dans les annales du protocole,
on y a dressé
une vaste tente bédouine.
Ils ont accepté
toutes nos demandes.
Le message de Kadhafi
pour sa première visite en Occident
après une longue
période de rupture c'était,
ce n'est pas parce que
je me rends en Europe, que je change.
Voilà qu'un grain de sable
vient gripper le bel ordonnancement.
Personne à l'Élysée
ne s'est aperçu que le dictateur arrive
à une date un peu particulière.
La Journée internationale
des droits de l'Homme.
Or, le président a justement
nommé une secrétaire d'État
chargée de ce sujet-là.
Avant cela,
j'ai rencontré les infirmières Bulgares
que je n'avais jamais
rencontrées depuis.
Je suis sortie
de cette rencontre bouleversée
parce qu'elles m'ont raconté
les conditions de leur détention
avec les attaques des chiens,
des choses absolument cauchemardesques
qu'on ne lisait même pas dans la presse.
Ça a modifié
évidemment mon regard.
J'ai essayé
de demander un changement de date
parce que le 10 décembre était symbolique,
il n'y avait pas d'argumentaire.
C'est comme ça.
C'est décidé, c'est calé.
Je n'avais pas à me mêler
du domaine réservé du président.
Alors à l'heure du laitier,
ce lundi matin,
la jeune secrétaire d'État
frappe un grand coup.
À un journal, elle lance :
« La France n'est pas un paillasson
sur lequel un dirigeant peut venir
s'essuyer les pieds de ses forfaits. »
Avant de rééditer à la radio,
« Je me retrouve avec une journée
des droits de l'Homme sur les bras
et Khadafi à Orly.
Pour moi c'est un problème. »
Au retour de la radio,
vers 9 h, 9 h 30,
le président m'appelle
en me disant de venir le voir à l’Élysée.
Il était silencieux,
me tournant le dos face à la fenêtre
et le silence dure très longtemps.
Puis arrivent les deux conseillers,
messieurs Levitte et Guéant,
qui me sermonnent lourdement.
Rendez-vous compte,
son avion est dans le ciel français.
Il ne veut pas atterrir.
Je lui dis écoutez,
qu'il rentre chez lui.
Il me dit,
ce n'est pas le moment de plaisanter.
J'ai arrêté de plaisanter
et je lui dis effectivement,
c'est très sérieux
et Nicolas Sarkozy les arrête
et puis leur demande
de préparer la suite avec moi,
à savoir qu'est-ce que je dis maintenant ?
Ils m'ont envoyée sur Europe 1.
J'ai essayé
de tourner autour du pot.
La rebelle est contrainte
d'approuver du bout des lèvres
cette visite qui commence
décidément sous de mauvais auspices.
En fin d'une matinée pluvieuse,
le dictateur finit par débarquer à Orly
à la tête de ses amazones
et d'une suite de 200 personnes.
L'ancien parrain du terrorisme,
s'offre pour la première fois
une visite prestigieuse
dans une grande capitale occidentale.
Qui plus est, celle d'un pays
qu'il a longtemps combattu.
Se trouver là
est pour lui, un succès éclatant.
Il ne s'en cache pas.
Le programme qu'on lui a concocté
n'en est-il pas la preuve ?
D'abord, cette réception ici-même.
Puis à l'Assemblée nationale.
Enfin, ce dîner de gala
en son honneur.
Nous avons beaucoup apprécié
qu'on nous serve du couscous à l’Élysée.
C'était un message tout à fait positif.
Il était très heureux de tout ce que
le gouvernement français lui offrait.
Il a été accueilli
avec grande déférence.
Autant alors faire durer le plaisir.
En France, l'usage diplomatique
veut que les visites officielles
durent trois jours.
Le dictateur demande à prolonger
son séjour de trois de plus,
une semaine en tout.
Il ne s'est pas invité,
mais il a demandé à rester à Paris
et on lui a accordé,
puisqu'on souhaitait
que cette visite lui soit agréable.
À chaque jour, il inventait
un nouveau sujet de préoccupation.
Quand les Libyens vous disent écoutez,
« Je souhaite aller à Versailles
parce que j'ai toujours rêvé. »
Difficile de lui dire non,
vous n'allez pas aller à Versailles.
Non, non,
c'est trop pour vous.
Le touriste de marque fait
privatiser le célèbre château royal.
C'est là que le roi
recevait les ambassadeurs.
Avant de filer au Louvre,
puis de réclamer
d'autres divertissements encore
à des organisateurs
quelque peu dépassés.
Il avait décidé de visiter
Paris en bateau mouche.
Vous imaginez ce que ça représente
en termes de sécurité,
puisqu'il faut sécuriser
les berges, mais aussi des ponts.
Pourquoi ne pas lui dire non,
tout simplement ?
Difficile de refuser
à une personnalité qu'on reçoit
le droit de découvrir
Paris en bateau mouche.
Je suis parti
à la chasse à Rambouillet.
Je n'étais pas chasseur
puisqu'il n'y avait qu'un seul fusil,
c'était celui de Kadhafi.
Les services de sécurité
étaient en place depuis 9 h du matin
pour bloquer
au moment du passage du convoi,
le convoi est arrivé
vers 12 h 30, 13 h.
Les rues bloquées
exaspèrent les Parisiens.
La pompe déployée pour
un dictateur choque les Français.
Ils assistent
à des scènes comme celle-là,
de pacifiques opposants en exil,
séquestrés dans
un car des heures durant,
afin d'éviter que le dirigeant libyen
ne les aperçoive sur son passage.
Les plus sidérés sont les proches
des 170 victimes de l'attentat
commis sur ordre du dictateur
contre un avion français en 1989.
Ce jeune homme y a perdu son père.
On n'oublie pas.
Imaginez dans dix ans,
le président américain
qui reçoit Ben Laden à la Maison-Blanche
et qui lui fait signer des contrats.
Quatre ans auparavant,
le dictateur a consenti
à indemniser les familles
des victimes du DC10 d'UTA,
mais il refuse toujours d'extrader
les auteurs de l'attentat.
Parmi lesquels
son propre bras droit.
Avant sa venue à Paris,
les familles avaient demandé
à être reçues par le président.
Un de ses collaborateurs
les avait éconduit.
Il me dit ce n'est pas grave, on ne fait
pas d'omelette sans casser des œufs.
On ne va pas s'embêter s'il y a
un peu de poussière dans les coins.
J'étais assez choqué
par cette vision des choses.
Ce à quoi il a dit
on ne pourra pas vous recevoir.
Il n'en est pas question,
ça ferait un incident diplomatique.
On est resté là-dessus.
Au cours de la visite,
le président est contraint
de faire volte-face
devant les caméras pour
donner un gage à l'opinion
ou par crainte d'un scandale.
Je crois qu'il était un peu angoissé
à l'idée de nous voir.
D'où le fait
qu'il était dans un monologue.
Il disait que bien
qu'il y avait beaucoup de fatwa contre lui
et qu'il était victime lui-même en disant
qu'il était visé par le terrorisme,
il a voulu créer
l'empathie avec nous.
À mon avis,
ce n'était pas le bon canal.
Il voulait montrer
que lui-même était une victime.
Résumons, le président invite le dictateur
pour sauver des victimes bulgares,
refuse de recevoir d'autres victimes
françaises du terrorisme libyen,
les reçoit finalement
et se pose lui-même en victime.
Le coup diplomatique
vire à la farce
et à la crise
médiatico-politique.
Une visite qui dérange,
des voix qui s'élèvent.
C'est la question du jour.
Le président libyen est-il
oui ou non le bienvenu ?
C'est une erreur incompréhensible.
Nicolas Sarkozy dit qu'il a changé.
C'est faux.
L'affaire des infirmières bulgares,
quand on prend cinq otages,
qu'on les torture,
qu'on les martyrise pendant des années
et qu'on les rend contre rançon,
ça s'appelle comment ?
Face à la multiplication des critiques,
le susceptible dictateur riposte
en organisant à l'Unesco
un meeting à sa gloire.
Ils font la surenchère
sur les droits de l'Homme.
Comment osent-ils ?
Avant de parler des droits
de l'homme dans vos pays
il faudrait encore que les immigrés
bénéficient chez vous de ces droits.
Nous n'avions prévenu
personne de cette initiative
et je peux vous dire que les Français
qui organisaient la visite
ont été très vexés
par le discours de Frère Mouammar.
Cette visite tourne
à la farce tragi-comique.
Que des relations diplomatiques
normales soit établies avec la Libye,
cela se conçoit,
mais que la France fasse le cadeau
d'une réhabilitation à grand frais,
c'est une maladresse
qui nous coûtera.
Monsieur le ministre des Affaires
étrangères, Bernard Kouchner,
jusqu'où irez-vous
dans la négation de vous-même ?
La parole est à Monsieur
le ministre des Affaires...
Jusqu'à présent
le chef de la diplomatie,
caution humanitaire du président,
c'était prudemment tenu
à l'écart de la visite controversée.
Vous avez cité un certain nombre
des prises de position
de Monsieur Kadhafi.
Sachez que je les réprouve.
Lorsqu'il a parlé
des droits de l'Homme ici,
c'est-à-dire des droits de l'Homme
dans notre pays et en Europe,
c'était assez pitoyable.
Je dis c'est pitoyable,
oui, c'est ce que je pense.
Je n'avais pas changé
lorsque Nicolas Sarkozy m'a proposé
d'être ministre des affaires étrangères,
il savait très bien à qui il demandait.
Je sentais bien que tout
ça l'avait agacé, bien sûr.
De l'autre côté de la rue,
pour le dictateur, c'en est trop.
Il attendait que cette visite
consacre sa respectabilité.
Au lieu de cela, on injurie,
on le juge pitoyable.
Il soupçonne le président
lui-même de le trahir,
car enfin, un ministre peut-il agir
sans l'accord de son chef ?
Devant ses conseillers,
il entre dans une colère terrible.
Kadhafi a été trompé par Sarkozy.
Kadhafi, lui,
était clair comme de l'eau de roche
et Sarkozy s'est comporté avec fourberie.
C'était une attitude
contraire à toute diplomatie.
Pour nous, musulmans et diplomates,
c'était un comportement inadmissible.
S'il le détestait,
pourquoi l'invitait-il en France ?
L’accueillait-il chaleureusement ?
Pourquoi était-il
venu le visiter en Libye ?
Tout ça, c'était de l'hypocrisie.
La situation s'envenime encore
lorsque le président tente désespérément
de désamorcer la polémique
qui agite la France.
C'est bien beau les leçons
de droits de l'Homme
et les postures
entre le Café de Flore et le Zénith.
Ces postures,
elles ont laissé pendant huit ans
ces malheureuses infirmières.
J'ai dit au président Kadhafi
combien il fallait continuer à progresser
sur le chemin
des droits de l'Homme.
Dans tous ses aspects.
Tout ce qu'il restait à faire.
Maintenant, ce président
lui fait publiquement la leçon.
La coupe est pleine.
La vengeance est un plat
qui se mange froid.
Aussi, le dictateur ne laisse
rien paraître de son courroux
lorsqu'il va retrouver son hôte.
Le dernier entretien qui s'est
fait Sarkozy a tenu à le recevoir.
C'est le président Sarkozy
qui lui a dit,
je suis désolé si la presse
vous a mal accueilli, et cetera.
Kadhafi, très grand seigneur,
lui a répondu écoutez,
vous n'y êtes absolument pour rien,
la presse est libre dans votre pays.
Il dit c'est votre problème, la presse
française, n'est pas mon problème.
Moi je verrai avec la mienne
à mon retour, mais je n'ai aucun souci.
Il a même dit en plaisantant
je n'ai aucun souci avec ma presse.
Justement, la presse française,
à laquelle il a promis une interview,
va être l'instrument de sa vengeance.
Ça tourne pour tout le monde, ça marche ?
OK, alors on y va.
Trois deux, un.
Alors, cette visite en France
provoque ici un vif débat
et le boycott de certains élus.
Comment réagissez-vous
à cette controverse ?
Je ne suis pas au courant,
je n'ai pas lu la presse
et je n'ai pas la télévision.
Le président Nicolas Sarkozy
a indiqué hier
qu'il vous avait demandé de progresser
sur le chemin des droits de l'Homme.
Non, moi et le Président Sarkozy
nous n'avons pas évoqué ces sujets.
Nous sommes amis, nous coopérons.
- Ça n'a pas été évoqué ?
Absolument pas, pas un instant.
- Vous pouvez le remercier encore.
Le missile est envoyé.
La presse fait des gorges chaudes
de ce cinglant démenti du dictateur.
Merci beaucoup.
Mortifié, publiquement humilié,
le président tente de faire
bonne figure en sortant son joker.
Je vais signer une dizaine
de milliards de contrats
avec la partie libyenne, c'est pour
l'emploi et la croissance des Français.
Que les choses soient claires,
je suis là aussi
pour me battre aux côtés
des entreprises et des usines françaises
pour que nous ayons
les contrats et les commandes
que les autres étaient tellement
contents d'avoir à notre place.
Sans rien renoncer de mes convictions
en matière de droits de l'Homme.
Alors, le président convie la presse
à une édifiante cérémonie.
- Un texte portant
sur l'achat de quinze appareils,
dont sept A320,
quatre A330 et quatre A350.
Rafales, hélicoptères, avions de ligne.
La liste est impressionnante.
Pourtant, les deux hommes
ne s'accordent pas un regard.
Le dictateur ravale sa colère.
À ce président indigne de confiance,
il va faire payer
une addition à sa manière.
Infirmières contre visite à Paris,
il s'estime quitte.
Kadhafi mentait.
Tous les contrats ensuite,
qui ont été signés
ou proposés à Paris,
il y en a aucun
qui a été suivi d'effet.
Voilà, c'était un fiasco.
Tout était compliqué,
on prend des engagements,
on les défait, on les renégocie,
on fait traîner.
On aurait vendu beaucoup de rafales
si toutes les promesses,
tous les engagements
signés avaient été tenus.
Les affaires ne peuvent pas se faire
sans qu'il y ait une politique
extérieure cohérente et rassurante.
C'est ça, quand je vous dis des amateurs.
Ironie de l'histoire,
la France aura après la visite,
moins de parts de marché en Libye
qu'à l'arrivée au pouvoir du président.
Même la centrale nucléaire
ne se vend pas.
L'industriel Areva s'y oppose,
jugeant insensée
cette volonté présidentielle.
L'année suivante,
en juillet 2008,
le président accueille à Paris
le sommet fondateur
de son union pour la Méditerranée,
devant une quarantaine de chefs d'État.
Mesdames et messieurs,
avec le président Moubarak,
nous déclarons ouvert
le sommet fondateur
de l'union pour la Méditerranée...
Le seul qui,
fidèle à son imprévisibilité,
a décidé de déclarer forfait
c'est finalement Kadhafi.
Il a déclaré forfait,
mais il a boudé en disant
ce n'est pas
comme ça qu'il fallait le faire.
Ce qui a mené Kadhafi
à la rupture avec Sarkozy,
c'est la quête
de leadership de Sarkozy.
Pour Kadhafi,
les pays africains sont au nombre de 54,
ils sont plus nombreux
que les pays européens.
Préférant rester
maître sur son continent,
le dictateur multiplie
les déclarations hostiles
à l'union pour la Méditerranée.
Fragilisée dès ses débuts
par l'absence de la Libye,
cette union ne verra jamais le jour.
L'aventure libyenne
est pour le président un échec cuisant.
Elle a mis en lumière ses défauts,
son exercice solitaire du pouvoir,
un certain amateurisme.
Cela explique sans doute
qu'elle coïncide dans les sondages
avec le début
d'une impopularité durable.
Dans les trois années suivantes,
le président ne veut plus
entendre parler du dictateur.
Jusqu'à un certain jour de février 2011.
Qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé au Moyen-Orient ?
Une chose extraordinaire.
C'est que les peuples arabes
ont décidé sans violence,
de prendre
leur destin en main.
Ces peuples aspirent
à la démocratie et au progrès social.
Alors que jusqu'à présent,
on avait plutôt
des régimes autoritaires
dont nous avions
des rapports avec eux,
parce qu'ils étaient laïcs
et parce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'autre solution d'alternative crédible.
Aujourd'hui,
il y a cette alternative.
Il se trouve en Turquie
lorsqu'il réagit
à une stupéfiante nouvelle.
Début 2011, des révolutions ont balayé
deux membres éminents de son UPM,
l'Égyptien Moubarak
et le Tunisien Ben Ali.
Voici que les Libyens, à leur tour,
se soulèvent contre leur dictateur.
Lui n'hésite pas à faire mitrailler
la foule de ses opposants.
Notre position est claire.
Monsieur Kadhafi doit partir.
Comme tous
les dirigeants occidentaux,
le président s'empresse de condamner
le désormais indéfendable guide libyen.
Ces mots ont bien peu de poids.
Alors que les printemps arabes
ont la sympathie de l'opinion,
le souvenir de sa lune de miel
avec le dictateur sanglant
est devenu gênant.
Ce bilan diplomatique
ternit tombe au plus mal
car dans un an,
il remettra en jeu son mandat.
Si, au contraire,
il tirait avantage de la situation
pour se représidentialiser ?
C'est ce que lui suggère
de faire un de ses conseillers.
La situation internationale nous permet
de tenter une opération politique
dictée par les événements.
Le message de dimanche soir
est extrêmement important.
C'est de là
que peut s'amorcer la reconquête.
Mes chers compatriotes,
c'est mon devoir de prendre
les décisions qui s'imposent
quand les circonstances l'exigent.
Nous avons donc le devoir
d'agir face à la crise libyenne,
dont les conséquences pourraient
être très lourdes
pour la stabilité de toute la région.
Le président de la République,
lui, a été mobilisé tout de suite,
a très bien compris
que cette affaire
allait tourner à la tragédie
avec des dimensions effroyables.
Le souvenir que je garde,
c'est qu'il m'avait demandé à l'époque
comment s'était déroulée
l'affaire de Srebrenica,
puisque j'étais auprès
du président Chirac à l'époque.
Calculs et convictions,
sans doute se mêlent.
Début mars, le président fait planifier
une action militaire,
seul ou presque,
parmi les dirigeants occidentaux.
Nul ne sait comment intervenir
dans une situation
de plus en plus chaotique.
Par qui remplacer le dictateur ?
Voilà que le 5 mars,
le président reçoit l'appel providentiel
d'un donneur
de leçons du Café de Flore
qu'il vitupérait en 2007.
Bernard-Henri Levy,
le philosophe médiatique,
se trouve à Benghazi,
fief de l'insurrection,
auprès des chefs des rebelles.
J'ai appelé tout bêtement
le standard de l'Élysée que par miracle,
j'avais sur un agenda
électronique avec moi.
Président de la République,
Nicolas Sarkozy
au bout du fil, je lui ai dit que
je suis avec les nouveaux dirigeants
du Conseil national de transition
qui vient de se créer.
Accepteriez-vous ?
Accepterais-tu,
on est vite repassés au tutoiement,
d'autrefois, de les recevoir ?
Il m'a répondu oui, naturellement.
Question, mais quand ?
Le plus vite possible qu'ils viennent.
Il a commencé par nous parler
de la visite de Kadhafi à Paris.
Il nous a dit
que Kadhafi était le président d'un pays.
Il fallait le recevoir.
Je l'ai reçu. Vous comprenez ?
Je n'étais pas sûr
de lui faire confiance à cause du passé.
Je n'avais pas le choix.
Maintenant que le peuple libyen
a fait un autre choix,
je suis prêt à vous aider.
Sarkozy nous a dit
qu'il reconnaissait le CNT
comme unique représentant
du peuple libyen.
Ils ne le croyaient tellement pas.
Tout ça, naturellement
je suppose, doit être secret.
Sarkozy feint de réfléchir
regarde Levitte puis Guéant
Secret, oui je ne sais pas non.
Monsieur le président,
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose
de nouveau sur la Libye ?
Un coup de théâtre.
Le président saute sur l'occasion
de reconnaître ses opposants
comme le seul pouvoir légitime de Libye.
Sa décision revient tout bonnement
à destituer le dictateur honnit.
Cela vaut bien
de prendre quelques risques.
En effet, nul ne connaît
la capacité de ce CNT,
Conseil National de Transition,
à gouverner demain.
Nul ne sait quels poids pèsent
au juste les islamistes.
Les Français se mettent en avant
d'une façon spectaculaire
qui heurte profondément
et qui n'est pas comprise,
ni par les Britanniques qui vont
devenir nos alliés et qui sont sidérés.
Je ne parle même pas
des autres partenaires européens.
Merkel est furieuse.
Les Américains
sont encore plus sidérés.
D'ailleurs les Américains
pendant très longtemps
vont continuer
de poser la question.
Qui sont ces gens ?
Disposant évidemment
d'informations précises
sur le passé de certains
et très inquiets à Washington
de la composante islamiste,
du risque de dérapage,
de ce qu'il adviendrait de tout cela.
Bien sûr, c'était un risque
et même éventuellement
une menace sur l'avenir.
Enfin, on avait le choix entre soutenir
ce Conseil National de Transition
et tous ceux qui l'entouraient
et ceux qui l'entourait.
Forcément, dedans, car il y avait
toutes les forces hostiles au régime,
il y avait aussi des forces plus
ou moins menaçantes.
C'était ça ou Kadhafi.
Un mot sur la situation s'il vous plaît ?
Il a été stupéfait
que Sarkozy s'ingère dans ce conflit.
Ils n'ont même pas cherché à dialoguer.
Aucun émissaire français
n'est venu sur place en Libye.
Il semble qu'il y avait déjà un plan
pour se débarrasser de Kadhafi.
La France se prend pour qui ?
Elle veut nous attaquer ?
Tu penses
qu'attaquer la Libye est facile ?
Espèce de crétin !
Nous, on va t'attaquer.
Tu veux attaquer ?
Essaye pour voir !
Fou de rage,
le dictateur commet l'erreur
d'envoyer ses chars
contre la ville rebelle de Benghazi.
- C'est bon, l'affaire est réglée !
Nous arrivons !
Pas de pitié
ni de clémence pour eux !
Sans le savoir,
il donne un coup de pouce décisif
au président qui,
en moins de dix jours,
parvient à réunir
une coalition internationale
et à obtenir une résolution de l'ONU.
Le 19 mars, à l'instant même
où ses alliés se réunissent à l’Élysée,
le président leur apprend que deux Rafales
viennent de tirer leur premier missile
sur les troupes du dictateur.
C'est le début
de huit mois de guerre.
J'ai un souvenir assez précis
à titre personnel,
puisque Nicolas Sarkozy me reçoit
juste après la décision
d'envoyer l'aviation
au dessus de Benghazi.
Hillarie Clinton
parle d'une guerre obsessionnelle.
La guerre de Sarkozy,
elle emploie ce mot là.
C'est vrai qu'il y a ce côté-là.
Il est complètement habité par ça.
Il a fait installer
la carte de la Libye dans son bureau,
il la connaît par cœur.
Il a un point précis en permanence
par son chef d'état-major.
Lui intervenait,
commentait les cartes.
En effet,
le président Sarkozy trouvait toujours
des petits points de progrès
puisque les couleurs étaient différentes.
Il connaissait absolument
par cœur chaque petit village
tenu par les uns
ou par les autres.
Retranché dans sa capitale,
le dictateur résiste mieux que prévu
à la guerre du président.
De son arsenal,
il dégaine même une arme nouvelle.
Je suis vraiment en colère.
C'est moi qui ai aidé Sarkozy
à prendre le pouvoir.
Je lui ai donné l'argent
avant qu'il ne devienne président.
Il est venu ici,
il m'a rendu visite sous ma tente
quand il était ministre
de l'intérieur et m'a demandé de l'aide.
Selon moi,
il a un problème mental.
Kadhafi disait la pure vérité.
Il a dit
ce qu'il avait à dire et c'est tout.
C'était plutôt un reproche.
Il ne pensait pas dévoiler
un grand secret à ce moment-là.
On t'a aidé à arriver à l'Élysée
et toi, tu fais une chose pareille.
C'est un peu comme si Hitler,
dans son bunker, avait accusé
Churchill d'avoir
utilisé l'argent des nazis
pour financer
ses campagnes électorales.
Je crois qu'il n'a jamais imaginé
qu'on puisse donner le moindre crédit
à ce genre de paroles.
Couverte
par le bruit des bombes,
l'accusation n'est pas étayée
par le dictateur,
mais elle finira par resurgir.
Au large de Tripoli, le président,
lui, vient encourager ses troupes.
Débuté six mois plus tôt,
le conflit s'enlise,
la rébellion piétine.
Le chef des armées
fait intensifier les opérations
et parachuter
des tonnes d'armes aux opposants libyens.
Autant autour de lui,
il y a eu parfois du flottement
chez des membres du gouvernement.
Tout le monde n'était pas convaincu
à Paris de la nécessité d'agir en Libye.
Lui était déterminé
jusqu'au bout dans les échanges
qu'il a avec
des gens à ce moment-là.
C'est, je vais le mettre à genoux,
il va mordre la poussière.
Je n'ai pas entendu des expressions
de ce genre, mais ce n'est pas impossible.
Ce n'est pas impossible
parce que des deux côtés,
évidemment, le ton monte.
Ça devient une espèce
de défi presque personnel.
Il faut qu'il y en ait un
qui perde et qui perde tout.
Celui qui perd tout,
c'est bien sûr le dictateur.
À la fin de l'été 2011,
son palais tombe aux mains de ses ennemis.
Deux mois plus tard,
son convoi est attaqué
par des avions français.
Lui-même est capturé par des rebelles.
Est-ce que vous avez une réaction
à la mort de Monsieur Kadhafi ?
L'objectif, c'est que la Libye
retrouve sa liberté
et un espoir démocratique.
On ne doit jamais se réjouir
de la mort d'un homme,
quel que soit
ce qu'il ait fait, jamais.
La menace
que faisait peser Kadhafi
sur l'avenir de la Libye.
Septembre 2011.
Lorsqu'il foule le sol libyen
pour la troisième fois de sa vie,
il est un président
débarrassé de son dictateur.
Il faut que
tous les dictateurs du monde
comprennent que
dans le monde du XXIᵉ siècle,
il n'y aura pas un endroit
où ils pourront
s'assurer de leur impunité.
L'impunité, c'est fini.
Je vous remercie.
Dans l'euphorie de sa victoire,
il a presque les mêmes mots
que pendant sa campagne de 2007.
Comme si,
de cette manière,
il voulait effacer les cinq années
de sa relation avec le dictateur.
Comme si, à quelques mois
d'une autre campagne électorale,
il venait conclure ici
cette peu glorieuse histoire.
Pourtant,
alors qu'il repart,
en Libye, la suite
de l'histoire s'écrit déjà.
L'opposition qu'il a soutenue
échoue à gouverner.
Une guerre civile éclate.
Le pays implose.
Les islamistes s'implantent.
La région est en proie au chaos.
En provoquant la chute du dictateur,
il a évité un massacre,
mais créé un monstre.
Le suivi,
c'est-à-dire l'après-guerre,
n'a pas été suffisant.
Je crois qu'il aurait été souhaitable
d'être plus présent
pour les aider à construire.
Ce n'était pas leur choix,
mais ça aurait dû être notre devoir.
Si on devait
avoir un regret à exprimer.
J'ajoute que cette période-là
a coïncidé avec nos élections,
l'arrivée d'un nouveau président
de la République et donc,
par la force des choses
ou du calendrier démocratique français,
nous nous sommes trouvés
dans une période de transition.
La faute donc
à des élections françaises
que sa guerre en Libye
n'aura pas permis de remporter.
L'histoire ne s'arrête pas là.
Après son départ de l’Élysée,
continue de planer au-dessus de sa tête
comme une malédiction.
À moins que ce ne soit
la morale de cette fable.
À la suite du dictateur,
des affairistes déçus
et d'anciens caciques du régime
l'accusent d'avoir reçu de l'argent libyen
pour sa campagne de 2007.
Soupçon infamant
qui ternit ses ambitions futures.
S'est-il compromis,
ou bien président d'une démocratie
paie-t-il tout simplement
le fait de s'être aventuré
avec un tel dictateur ?
Le colonel Kadhafi aurait
financé votre campagne en 2007.
Est-ce que c'est vrai ?
S'il l'avait financée,
je n'aurais pas
été très reconnaissant.
Il avait dit quelque chose
autour de 50 millions
ou quelque chose comme ça.
Tous les rendez-vous
avec Kadhafi sont enregistrés
et c'est ça qui leur fait peur.
Nous affirmons, sur la base
de plusieurs témoignages et de documents,
qu'il y a eu un financement
à hauteur de 50 millions.
Vous croyez vraiment
qu'avec ce que j'ai fait,
Monsieur Kadhafi
m'a fait un virement ?
Pourquoi pas un chèque endossé ?